Herkese merhaba Ben Deniz mısınız
iyisinizdir Ama eğer iyi değilseniz de
hiç sorun değil Çünkü bugün tam olarak
bu konuyu konuşmak için bu benim
sizlerle Ben geçtiğimiz yaz bir
depresyon geçirdim Hem de öyle minnoşun
battaniye altında dizi izleyeyim kahve
içeyim İşte biz insanın uzaklaşıyorum
falan da değil Bayağı Gecenin bir vakti
böyle bir uyanıp işte Devlet Hastanesi
koştur koştur gidip o böyle floresan
Işık altında işte derisinden böyle
uyurduk derisinden sünger fırlamış irenç
Seddi uzanıp kalçadan Böyle ağır bir
sakinleştirici iğne yaptırmalı cinsten
bol geceleri olan ağır Okkalı bir
depresyon geçirdim Ama bu can kısımları
can sıkıcı kısımları geçeceğim Çünkü
zaten Bence Depresyon nasıl bir hastalık
olduğunu hiçbir şey değilse Hani Cannes
ödüllü bir sürü biliyorsunuz Iğdır
311 ince insanın aklında karanlık Odalar
böyle loş Işıklı bölgelerin uzadığı işte
zamanın asla akıp geçmediği böyle Ölüm
Sessizliği içinde sadece duvardaki böyle
bir dede yadigarı saatten depo sesler
geldiği sahneler hayal ediyor genellikle
iş depresyona girmemiş olan insanlar Ama
eğer onlardan biriyseniz ben size
depresyona girmiş bir insan olarak davet
edebilirim ki çok daha köpüklü gerçekten
Depresyonda dibe vurduğunuzda
yaşayabileceğimiz bizleri belki
anlatabilecek bir film olan yok ve ben
yaşamış biri olarak söyleyeyim ki
filmlerde estetize edildiğinden çok daha
beter gerçekteki depresyon hissi
hayatınızda son vermek için muhtaç
olduğumuz Kudret in damarlarınızda
ve asil kanda mevcut olduğunu
hissediyorsunuz ama çok tuhaf bir
şekilde yani benimle kulağıma hala garip
bir cümle söyleyeceğim şimdi ben size
ben Depresyona girdim için çok mutluyum
yani misin sen diyeceğiz tahmin ediyorum
haklısınız bunu ilk söylediğimde Ben de
acaba mollusc ismim diye düşündüm durdum
kendi içime baktım mutlu olması BİM'in
depresyona acı çekmem falan olmadığını
anladım Benim bugün şu anda bu konuşmayı
yaparken
da içinde bulunduğu andan bu düz anda
müthiş yüze duyuyor onun sebebi benim bu
yaz çok ağır bir depresyon geçirmiş ve
bunu atlatmış olmam aslında Bu Benim İlk
depresyonum Değil de ilkini On yaşında
Annemle babam beni bir başka bir şehre
yatılı okula yollayıp üstüne de
arkasından Biz boşanıyoruz habere
verdiklerinde geçirmiştim teşekkürler
Anne baba sonra ilk mesleğim olan yine
ailem sayfa seçtiğimde Her gününden
nefret ettiğim Diş hekimliğini Daha
doğrusu Çene Cerrahisi kariyerimi
bırakıp her şeyi sıfırdan başlayıp
reklam yazarı olmaya karar verdim
dönemde ikinci bir Depresyonda geçirdim
sonra birkaç sene önce çok sevdiğim bir
insanı kaybetme ihtimaliyle hastane
koridorlarında yatıp kalktığım bir
dönemim oldu orada bir tane daha
depresyon geçirdim Bir de en son bu
geçtiğimiz
ve depresyon daha geçirdim Yani şöyle
bir bakacak olursak ben depresyon
konusunda oldukça Temiz olsaydı bunu
kolayca dile getirebilirim gururla
Depresyonda tecrübeli bir insan olarak
şunu söyleyebilirim açıcı olanlar diyor
ya ilki çok zor sonra ikimiz de birazcık
da kullanıyorsun üçüncüde Onun da
sallıyorsun diyor Tabii ki öyle donunuzu
elinizde sağlayarak olan ruh adet
kaldıracak geziyorsunuz nasıl ki üçüncü
çocuğu olan bir anne baba çocuğunu gece
uyandığında Hani Kahkahalar atarak neşe
içinde İyi ki uyandım demiyorsa Siz de
aynı şekilde Tabii ki neşe içinde
olmuyorsunuz Ama eğer ortak noktamız
olan uykusuz gecelerden gidecek olursak
Eğer artık İkincide değilse de üçüncüde
muhakkak bir şeyler öğrenmiş oluyorsunuz
mesela uykusuz Gecelerim Sizi
öldürmeyeceğim mi ve her ne kadar
ne diyecekmiş gibi dursa da sonsuza
kadar sürmeyeceğini bir gün muhakkak o
acının son bulacağını artık öğrenci
oluyorsunuz o yüzden de en korkunç
gecede bile Kendinizi çok kötü
hissediyor olduğunuzda bile birazcık
zamanın geçmesini odaklanmamız
gerektiğini biliyorsunuz ve bunu
yapıyorsunuz Ben öyle yaptım zaten böyle
acıdan ölecek gibi olup daha fazla
dayanamayacağım hissettiğimde ve Şeytan
böyle Nuri bizdeki elektronik dans
partilerinde çalan böyle bir diyeceğim
gibi beni gazladı ında Hadi aç şu ucunu
doğalgazını Hadi vermiştik olanı
dediğinde ki bu arada doğalgaz faturası
evinize geldiğinde ödemek için orada
olması çok cezbedici geliyor böyle
karanlık gecelerde insana neyse işte o
zaman ben şöyle diyorum kendime on
saniye da yandınız sadece onu saniye bu
kadarını yapabilirsin 1 2 3 4
GTA 5 6 7 8 9 10 10 bayramınız bu
şekilde Böyle on saniye on saniye ya
gittim birkaç ay boyunca böyle
apartmanın içinde tek başına kalmış bir
depremin bitmesini Sarsıntı bitmesini
bekleyen bir çocuk gibi kendi kendimi
sakinleştirmeye çalıştım ve sonunda
deprem bitti bittiğinde Dışarı çıkıp
baktım ve her depremde olduğu gibi
gördüğüm manzara şuydu Depreme dayanıklı
olmayan tüm yapılar çökmüştü reklam
ajanslarından Nefes almadan geçen
çalışma hayatım yürümeyen toksik
ilişkilerim vs şimdi sayamayacağım Bu da
canınızı sıkmayın daha birçok çürük Yapı
depremle birlikte çökmüştü Ben enkazın
tepesinde Hani İstanbul'un fethinde su
ve bu ilk bayrağı diken Ulubatlı Hasan
var ya onun gibi elinde bayrağıyla
enkazı tepesinde bir kahraman gibi siz
olun kendime çünkü çok kuşların sonunda
İnsanlar kendilerini genellikle kahraman
gibi hissederler Neden Çünkü artık
kaybedecek her şeyinizi kaybettiğiniz
için kaybetme korkunuz da kaybetmiş
oluyorsunuz ve dolayısıyla etrafınızı
Sadece bu elimdeki sıfırın üstüne ben ne
ekleyebilirim diye bir heyecanla ve
dolayısıyla korkuda kalmadığı için
içinin cesaretle bakmaya başlıyorsunuz
benim de hayatımda böyle canımı sıkan
içime dert olan işte benim böyle
hareketini engelleyen yani bileyim
Efendi olmuş Ne varsa işte böyle
ilişkisinden işine artık hepsinden
kurtulmuştum Hiç beni bağlayan birşey
kalmamıştı ve Hani bu işsiz ve ilişkisiz
ve servis kalmak belki dışardan
bakıldığında depresyona girmek için bir
sebep gibi görünebilir ama
da tam tersine depresyonla çıkma sebebim
oldu çünkü artık istemediğim Herşeyden
kurtulmuştum ve depresyondan
kurtulduktan Sonra şöyle bir şey oldu
ben sabah kalkıyorum dışını fırçalıyorum
ve bir anda Oha diyorum ben şu an acı
çekmiyorum bölmek istemiyorum Bu harika
bir şey bunu fark etmeme birlikte bir
anda Diş fırçalamak dediğimiz dünyanın
en sıkıcı aktivite dünyanın en güzel
aktivite dönüşüyor gaza gelip müziği
atıyorum böyle Amerikan
romantik-komedi-filmleri popomu sağladı
dans etmeye falan başlıyorum böyle kendi
kendime ondan sonra akşam oluyor yemek
siparişi vereceğim de salata mı söylesem
diyorum Böyle işte bir anlamda içinden
ses yok üç günlük dünya işte Ne rejimi
göm lahmacunu böyle salata bir lahmacun
derken bir anda Oha diyorum karar
veremediği şey bak sen daha dün
doğalgazı mı açsam yoksa iki kutu ilaç
Mutsan noktasında
Selam bugün lahmacun Musa'dan noktasına
geldiysen diyorum Deniz sana helal olsun
Sen şu an ne kadar harika veya
taşıyorsun canım ve acayip bir sevinç
geliyor bana ayağa kalk böyleydi tek
başıma Durduğum yerde böyle halay çeke
simgeliyor soba hala ve yani tahmin
ediyorum geçtiğimiz yaz depresyon
geçirmemiş insanlar yemek siparişi
verirken bilgisayar başında kararsız
kaldıklarında bu kadar coşkuyla
karşılıyorlar dır o anı O yüzden ben
şahsen huzurunuzda canım depresyonum a
çok teşekkür ederim Sen olmasaydın Şu an
şu dakika yorganın altında karanlık
düşüncelerle buluşarak tavanı izlemek
yerine böyle bir teleks konuşması
yapıyor olmamın ne kadar harika bir şey
olduğunun farkında olmazdı Muhtemelen
bunu normal bir an zannederdim Bu yüzden
ben seni tanıdığım için çok mutluyum Sen
bu ama gelince Bazen dolu metrobüsle
Söğütlüçeşme'ye sonra kadar gitmek bile
Sizler olabiliyor Her zaman değil o
yüzden seninle biz sana Görüşmesek de
olabilir bence aynı takılalım birisi
diyorum ama merak etme seni soran
herkese senden çok iyi bahsetmeye devam
edeceğim ben o yüzden bir daha görüşene
kadar Hoşça kal öpüyorum Güle güle